i'm merrick reichman
and i'm now going to talk you through
all the aston martin cars that appear in
the james bond movies
i'm an industrial designer and i trained
as an automotive designer wanted to be a
designer all my life and have been
designing aston martin for 15 years
[Music]
db5 goldfinger 1964.
it was an evolution of the db4 very
successful car for us used in racing but
it was very mechanical in a way and the
consumer wanted more luxury bigger seats
electric windows therefore the wheelbase
had to grow and the car needed more
power
beauty comes through proportion the body
to window height the overall length to
the length of the cabin the width of the
car to the grill all fit within the
golden proportion you'll be using this
aston martin db5 with modifications
now pay attention please it's so
difficult to pick a favorite gadget from
the car but a few got to mention the
wheel spinners and the bulletproof
shield but really the tracking system
which was a form of satellite navigation
system way back in 64 advanced
technology we were inspired by the the
anniversary of goldfinger to make some
continuation cars so we made 25
continuation db5s that have all of the
gadgets that you would see in the movie
the only thing that was missing was the
actual
ejector seat system on an opening roof
one year later it was 1965 and
thunderball featuring the db5 again
goldfinger made db5 a huge success by
the time we got to
thunderball db5 was going out of
production because we oversold we could
only make 11 cars a week and there was a
demand for 50. there were no differences
between the db5 in goldfinger and
thunderball it was a year later and
actually we'd only just started
production of the db5 so it was so
successful in the prior movie that it
was used again and there were no
differences same colour same colour
interior
on her majesty's secret service 1969
with the aston martin dbs
bill townes or william towns was a
designer like myself for aston martin
and was responsible for the aston martin
dbs and some of the lagongas one of the
leaders really and a hero of mine
because he brought some of the americana
type design to the uk the layout with
this brilliant engine in the front and
where you sit relative to the engine
makes the car and gives it that presence
but it had real power
[Music]
i like
all of the movies
i particularly like this one because of
the change of pace the change of scenery
the lighting the actor the gadget i.e
the car the dbs didn't have gadgets
because the car itself was the gadget it
was incredibly modern powerful car a new
generation of aston martins but it did
have an armalite ar7 in the glove box
[Music]
diamonds are forever 1971 and briefly
the aston martin dbs
the dbs appears in diamonds are forever
with rocket missiles being loaded into
the bonnet it doesn't appear driving in
the movie at all
the living daylights in 1987 with the v8
volante
after an absence of eight films the
living day lights featured the aston
martin v8 volante in 1987. there is a
little bit of confusion about the actual
car that was in the living daylights
because it starts life as a v8 valente
which is a retracting soft top so an
open top car but it gets winterized i.e
then it becomes the coupe version so a
v8 the v8 can be driven in snowy and icy
conditions the addition of winter tires
spiked tires would allow bond to drift
and drive the car beautifully on snow
and ice the retractable outriggers is
probably the only request we haven't had
for any of our cars we've had lots of
requests for many other things obviously
ballistic protection stowage of
weapons etc but no one's ever asked for
outriggers i do think absence makes the
heart grow fonder and for sure bond
didn't feel right without his aston
martin so it came back
and everything felt fine again
goldeneye and 95 and that was the db5
again one of my favorite scenes in all
of the movies is
the red ferrari versus the silver birch
db5 through the alps
drifting around the corners it's just an
iconic piece of film i love it i could
watch it over and over and over again
the db5 that appears in golden art is
actually not the original car which was
bmt216a this is bmt214a
if you're watching the movie so it is a
different car i think with the right
driver on those roads
a db5 could beat a modern day ferrari
because
the roads are narrow the corners are
incredibly tight and if you could drift
a db5 around the corners for sure you'd
beat one of those ferraris
tamora never dies 1997 and the db5 cara
appears briefly in tomorrow never dies
parked in a street in oxford
and bond has to get from oxford down
into london
die another day in 2002 with the all-new
aston martin vanquish
the aston martin vanquish really was the
start of a new era for aston martin it
was bonded aluminium using carbon fibre
and so we weren't welding the frames
we're now bonding those frames i think
if you look at vanquish it it is a
really muscular car i mean it's a very
powerful car and it signified a big
change for aston martin but it's very
much a technology story and i think it
suited brosnan and the bond because this
bond was all about technology if we look
at the cloaking device used on vanquish
it really was based on a technology that
was being looked at by the defense
ministry so actually not so preposterous
it was an idea of disguising objects
through reflective shields
casino royale in 2006 with the aston
martin dbs
dbs was a derivation of our very
successful db9 it was a wider car by
about 40 millimeters much more inclusion
of carbon fibers we gave it a huge power
upgrade the suspension was different
sport seats
so that gear shift timing was all
changed it was a much faster response
time quad exhaust pipes wider car
lighter in weight more powerful much
more aggressive so when they started
filming we'd begun the prototype
development in fact barbara michael
wilson daniel craig came to the studio
to see the car in clay i wanted a more
muscular powerful language for aston
martin i wanted something that really
evoked the v12 that sat midships at the
front of the car and as i presented it
was clear that that character of bond
was also
needed as well that bond was becoming a
little bit more hard edged more cutting
edge and that fit perfectly to the
vision of dbs the gadgets in dbs were
quite special because we were actually
involved in the design studio developing
the gadgets so one of my favorites is
when he receives the car he gets a
crystal key in an envelope in a crystal
box then when he needs the car he uses a
defibrillator that we actually designed
in the studio shape where it would fit
how it would attach to the body the
colour the graphic language originally
the gun was pointing towards the
driver's seat so we switched the gun
around so bond could grab the gun easier
so a lot of fun was had developing the
gadgets
quantum of solace in 2008 with the dbs
there were some minor differences
between the dbs that appears in casino
royale and the dbs in quantum of solace
the color is very different so on
quantum of solace the car is a darker
gray than the casino royale car casino
royale's dbs was an early prototype and
by the time we got to 2008 and quantum
of solace it was a full-on production
car so the seats are slightly different
the makeup of the interior is slightly
different i was actually at
uh millbrook when the rollover scene was
filmed vesper eva green is laid across
the road and he has to swerve
and the car was meant to land on its
roof come to a halt and then obviously
bond would be captured but the first few
times it was filmed the stunt driver
couldn't get the car to unearth itself
to roll which you should be able to do
but our car was very stable and you
couldn't so they had to deploy a cannon
into the car which is a kind of cylinder
that fires down to the ground and flips
the car over and obviously you would
normally test and test to how much
power you need to flip the car this was
done very quickly just make it happen
and so fire the cannon and the car
flipped and flipped and flipped and did
a world record seven and a quarter turns
when it was only really intended to do
one
sky 4 with the db5 in 2012 if you look
at skyfall
bond drives m all the way from london to
the highlands of scotland which is a
long journey that's
probably an eight or nine hour journey
up into the highlands
it's not very comfortable is it
[Music]
are you going to complain the whole way
oh go on then reject me see if i can
m statement about the db5 not being very
comfortable
actually the seats are pretty
comfortable in the db5 and the seating
position is quite comfortable the cars
were created as as
gt cars so grand touring cars cars
designed for long journeys the
difference today is that there are so
many aids and and advances in terms of
technology smoothness quietness seat
comfort ventilation
that make our journey so much more
pleasurable the journey would have been
great then but you just wouldn't have
the creature comforts
spectre db10 and db5 in
2015.
so spectra featured the db10 which was
the first time that a car had been
designed just for james bond and for the
movie barbara broccoli michael wilson
daniel craig and sam mendes came to see
me in the studio and up on the wall i
happened to have a sketch of a future
car which then became vantage
which was
sat next to a mood image of a shark and
it was
the db10 and as we were coming out of
the studio
daniel and sam happened to see the
sketch and say
what's that can we see that i said well
you can't see that it's just a sketch
and sam mendez looked at me said
but what is it i said well it's it's our
hunter it's our sports car two seats
only very agile more sporting very
dramatic just a single line lots of
power and he just looked at me and said
well can we have 10 of those
and i looked at my team i said when do
you need them by september this was
april and i just said yes we can do it
my team fell over but we produced 10
cars to support the movie so not only
did bond get a unique car designed for
him he also got the mark of db10 and
only 10 were ever made if you notice it
it doesn't have
traditional air venting it's got kind of
dot matrix pattern air vents on on the
hood and in terms of gadgets it was very
much how we use the car and how we how
the the
theme of the movie inspired what the car
should look like particularly from the
inside and this was a bit of kind of
post-modernist addition of objects it
wasn't the smooth interior this time it
was putting random switches so it looked
as though someone had developed the car
like it was a prototype
oh yes that old thing is taking quite a
bit of time
so you see the db5 in the movie when
james first bought the db10 and on a
bench is a db5 which is being restored
back to its former glory and then the
very last scene is james driving off
into the london sunset off on a journey
in the db5
valhalla
dbs v8 and db5 it's no time to die 20 21
if you
look back to the prior movie driving off
into the sunset in the db5
cut to no time to die the first scenes
beautifully photographed and beautifully
shot through
the italian village materia and it kind
of sets up the language for the movie
and
new gadgets donuts with gatling guns
that come out of the headlamps are just
a superb scene in the movie
the v8 appears in no time to die and
actually when kerry came to the studio
he saw
the v8 and immediately fell in love with
it because i think if you're a film
director the car holds light beautifully
well its presence is it's dramatic i
think if we look at the v8 versus the
db5 for james bond for daniel craig in
particular in no time to die
it really is a transition point for him
his character in the movie
so without giving too much away he comes
to a lockup and unveils dramatically the
v8 it's almost a i'm back moment the car
immediately stays power
the dbs superleggero really again has
going back to quantum of solace with the
dbs it's a very similar color so it's a
much darker
xenon gray we call it and this
really doesn't have any gadgets it's the
car itself which again
for aston martin is a it's a bonded
aluminium chassis with an all carbon
fiber exterior v12 lots of power
valhalla has a cameo roll and it's seen
behind m as m is having a very serious
conversation and the car is in a wind
tunnel
so you're not quite sure what the car is
going to be used for maybe it's a gadget
itself i think as ever the biggest
challenge with producing four cars for a
movie is it's always time i mean there
are very very strict filming schedules
and and
scenes areas are booked well in advance
and the multiples of cars potentially no
support not even a fueling station it
really is a logistical challenge but
obviously the timing challenge of
preparing all of the cars getting them
on site
and being part of the movie
aston martin partnered with goldfinger
in 1964 originally and from then on it's
been an amazing journey with all the
cars that you see behind me